you know on this show a couple days ago
we didn't expect it would get this bad
in ukraine we had several conversations
where you know i had said there's no way
that russia is going to move from the
north of ukraine or through belarus to
try and take kiev we had uh steve reneon
he's from fortitude ranch and i asked
him do you think putin would move from
eastern ukraine up to like as far west
as kharkiv and he's like no no it's
going to be southern land bridge
boy were we wrong because there's
reported attacks as far west as levi
which is basically it's very close to
poland and things are getting uh things
have gotten really really bad
so they're absolutely moving north
through belarus belarus has apparently
been like no we we don't know anything
about we got nothing to do with it the
u.s has got troops in poland the baltic
states are on high alert things are bad
i've got uh i spoke with a friend who's
from kiev who said yup war is here
they're concerned for their family and
so yeah dark times
but here's where it gets particularly
worrisome there's a few big stories
three in particular one is that nbc
reported joe biden has been presented
with plans
for the u.s to engage in cyber attacks
against russia against their
infrastructure which would mean
u.s directly and publicly attacking
russian infrastructure in response to
the war in ukraine that is a dramatic
and direct escalation it's effectively
this this article is is
threatening enough you know but putin's
probably got intelligence but if the u.s
were to actually
publicly say oh we're gonna we're gonna
cyber attack your trains and your
internet we're gonna disrupt your
economy
i don't see how that's not a declaration
of war
the next big story which is potentially
worse
is ukraine and boris johnson and many
others journalists blue checks all
saying ban russia from the swift payment
system that's international banking
if you do that the u.s petrodollar is is
is is out russia is not going to cease
to exist they have resources they're
going to be immediately working with
china china's already backing them up
kicking them off of swift would be
it would it would guarantee
international war as far as i'm
concerned now maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm
wrong and the last most important story
is china's defending russia they're
saying the u.s fan the flames the u.s
caused this problem and that taiwan is
basically the same as ukraine
and it's now it's now been reported that
china is basically saying they're going
to need russia's support because they
plan to do the exact same thing to
taiwan this is everything we feared
would happen that if russia moved into
ukraine in the distraction china would
make its move on moves on taiwan and it
seems like all of that is building up
now i don't believe
that biden will actually attack or there
will be cyber attacks but
even if they were to happen
we wouldn't know
they wouldn't come out and say hey we
did this
russia may not care they may view any
attack on their infrastructure from
anyone as joe biden at this point
imagine some rogue hacker group now goes
after their infrastructure and putin
says well biden was the one saying he
was going to do it who does he blame
we had a lot to talk about we got a lot
of stories to talk about this is crazy
stuff joining us to talk about all of
this is ian smith of attila's gym you
you had the the state government i
believe
and these police they come after you
because you refuse to shut down your gym
now you're running for office you want
to introduce yourself yeah
my name is ian smith i'm one of the
co-owners of the attila's gym of belmar
new jersey uh you may have heard of our
story over the past two years when we
reopened our business against lockdown
measures in
the state of new jersey and governor
phil murphy through pretty much all of
the weight of the new jersey government
and legal system against us we we went
to war with these people and
um 700 and some odd days later our gym
still is open we've amassed hundreds of
thousands of dollars of fines we've had
pretty much everything thrown at us but
the gym stayed open and so we we won
that battle and
we remain open every single day that was
our that was our mission from the
beginning so the rest of it will get
sorted out in in the court system slowly
but surely
and in the meantime i have launched a
congressional campaign in the third
district of new jersey
uh against
incumbent democrat andy kim and uh
we're gonna have some fun with it the uh
the goal the goal is to make politicians
really uncomfortable there you go you're
also gonna get thrown into the deep end
on foreign policy conversations now yeah
so this is good practice this is gonna
be interesting now what i think is
really interesting is uh it's ian's time
to shine because ian's been harping on
the swift payment system for some time
and here we go oh man so this is like
cancel culture at its worst if you think
you can cancel rush out of existence and
just close your eyes and they're gone
this is not
banning people from the
methodology of living on earth is not
the way to to make them get along with
you
i'm ready to talk about it tonight
talk to you soon
and i'm also here in the corner pushing
buttons very excited for this
conversation the world is looking a
little dark today so hopefully we should
shed some light on that we'll see what's
up before we get started head over to
timcast.com and become a member if you
would like to support our work as a
member you are making sure all of our
journalists remain employed that's how
we we pay everybody basically because
people have signed up but you'll also
get access to exclusive segments from
this show from the tim castro podcast
available again at timcast.com but don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and i'll just just one
more quick um
just to plug before we get started this
one's just for you guys to pay attention
and to be safe make sure you have you
have plans for the safety and security
of your family make sure you know if
you're in potential hot spots pay
attention to what's happening around the
world i don't know if this goes global
or whatever i'm just saying
having some food having some water
having a bug out kit having a plan
sometimes there's a fire sometimes
there's a hurricane you've got to
understand these things and i hope
everybody stays calm stay safe and
thinks things through because it could
get really spicy let's get started by
taking a look at this first story this
this one from nbc news
one of the most shocking stories and i
think
let me read the headline
biden has been presented with options
for massive cyber attacks against russia
the options presented include disrupting
the internet across russia shutting off
power and stopping trains in their
tracks they say
biden has been presented with with the
the menu of options for the u.s to carry
out cyber attacks to disrupt russia's
ability to sustain its military
operations in ukraine four people
familiar with the deliberations tell nbc
news this is important because they're
not talking about retaliation this is
not some story where they said we've
presented potential cyber attacks
against russia in the event they attack
us no this is we want to have the u.s
attack russia to stop their operations
in ukraine now many people have believed
that we should be backing up ukraine
many believe that we shouldn't
regardless
this story i believe is a threat to
vladimir putin the purpose of publishing
this is so that putin knows the u.s is
prepared to do it if the u.s wages cyber
war against russia going after their
internet their trains they are
attempting to [ __ ] their economy
economic damage is warfare
scary stuff man
yeah
it's i mean it's no different than if we
were to go and bomb these same train
routes you know there's less death and
violence but the same objective from a
warfare standpoint is achieved and
that's the shutting down of the economy
and that has
major repercussions that
no country is going to ignore so
when when you're putting these options
on the on the table you know you said it
perfectly are we thinking about
retaliation because
we're not immune to that we we've
already seen over the past year i mean
we've seen several cyber attacks over
the past year we know that our
uh networks are just as vulnerable if
not more vulnerable to those same cyber
attacks so do we really want to start
that tit for tat
no definitely that's i don't i don't
think there's a winner in that game it
may already be happening there was a
refi what was it the refinery explosion
yeah what was that last night or when
was it so that was the day before it was
yesterday i think and it just blew up
and they had no idea why so i still
didn't figure it out i was just like is
this possible
yeah just it was a food processing plant
exploded
hey look i don't want to i don't want to
connect dots where we have no reason to
connect
putin i was listening to an interview a
couple of years ago he was talking to
like a crowd and saying that america's
military defense capabilities basically
the last 20 to 30 years they've been
building up their defensive capabilities
against intercontinental ballistic
missiles and missile defense and now
that weaponry is so advanced and evolved
that all that defense's stuff is
obsolete and so all this american we
think we've got these great
complete obsolete lessons i mean it's
anyone that wants to kill right now any
government that wants to blow up a
country can do it i don't think they can
any any superpower us china or russia if
they want to level something they can
level it there's going to be
consequences obviously but
we're not safe
like we're not living in like a bubble
here guys i don't well just just imagine
if some way somebody were to shut off
the
the subway system in new york city
imagine the type of chaos that would
ensue from something just as as simple
as one target like that
that's that's an incred you don't need
bombs
you could you could turn a country
inside out on itself with some of these
cyber attacks you know you could cause
shortages in the supply chain you could
cause disruptions in major cities
imagine new york city in a traffic jam
of
nine million people who can't get around
all of a sudden what happens then
and a lot of people don't realize
because people have like a movie-esque
view of warfare
the targeting of civilians
wins you wars look at world war ii
we blew up two cities killed untold
numbers of i mean massive numbers of
civilians at least two cities and they
beg please please please stop
it's a scary thought but you've got a
lot of people who have this view of
warfare as like i love the idea of war
crimes
when you when you're dealing with the
idea of war crimes you're not really
dealing with real war necessarily what i
mean what i mean by that is
when you can wag your finger and say the
international court will hear what
you've done that's not war that that
that i mean it's it's it's like it's
it's a lower tier of what war could be
when you're talking about actual
existential war then you're talking
about people saying i am going to evis
scorched earth your cities because you
got to understand about targeting of
civilians who do you think is making the
machines who do you think is running the
economy who do you think is producing
the food it's not like military is is
hammering away and smelting it's not
like it's all military farming it's
regular people so when you look at say
the civil war sherman's march to the sea
that's what the north said we wipe out
the farms we wipe out the people we win
the war and boy is that dark stuff but
that's real war that's brutal war i'm
pretty sure dresden the reason that the
allies firebomb dresden in world war ii
which was really one of the greatest
atrocities of the war
arguably had to happen because that's
where but it was a weapons manufacturing
hub basically so they were like you know
what we're taking them all out full of
civilians this is it like if a terrorist
has a building
and they're firing at you and then they
have a family in there with them
do you unload on the building with your
with your m1 abram and just level it to
the ground the answer in warfare is yes
because you're being fired at from that
building they're usually
people will use human shields man i was
watching these videos out of ukraine and
uh the subway systems in kiev where
everyone was piling in trains what
people need to know is
the subway systems in in kiev i i
believe probably most of ukraine go deep
underground like legit when i was there
and i'm taking the train the escalators
going down
seemingly endless and it's because
during the cold war when they're
building these things they were worried
about nuclear strikes and trains are
extremely
if not the most important piece of
infrastructure oh yeah transporting
people and goods so they said if there's
one if we're going to protect anything
with deep underground bunkers we got to
get our train systems to move goods
you take a look there's a story out of
new york it's fascinating there's like a
secret room in grand central station
that contains this old machine that used
to run all of the tracks and it was
hidden behind like a secret wall or
something i don't know if you could
factor me on the story but something
like this the reason was if any of our
adversaries say cold war adversaries
found it shutting down that one machine
would [ __ ] the us economy
you got to understand man when the u.s
says we're going after your trains that
is level one of of starting the war we
are going to shut down your ability to
transport materials and and and maintain
your economy
and the report is so specifically we can
shut down your efforts in ukraine it's a
form of siege warfare really if you're
crippling their ability to transport
food to their citizens you're you're
putting them under siege and i think
it's i think it's
it's extremely reckless to put that
threat out in the open right it just it
seems it seems like a flagrant um
wag of the finger or a middle finger
into the face
of somebody who is clearly already
um
easily provoked yeah doesn't it seem
strange that we are having this
conversation about this doesn't this
seem like something we should keep on
the down low am i crazy
they're basically saying vladimir putin
we intend to attack you and they knew
having biden say this he'd come home
no we can't even let our president say
it we got to put it in the news yeah
that bad
what did someone say joe biden said chew
grain inside of ukraine or something
like that yeah someone said this i don't
know i didn't see the clip but uh
wow a president that can't command do
there's there's a whole bunch of memes
about you know what's going on and it's
like there's one it's braveheart and
it's like barack obama and then it's you
know mel gibson no and then trump comes
that says trump four four trumps you
know for each year and he's like hold
and then it's biden now
charge yeah it's it's look there's
something to be said for that there's
something to be said for the fact that
throughout love love them or hate them
throughout the trump years we didn't
have these type of situations
uh bubbling up to the surface right in
front of us where people seem to be able
to do whatever they want without fear of
recourse
i mean
that's there's something to be said for
that type of posturing and
i think if you want to keep the world a
safe place
you have to be able to
to do that to a certain extent you see
what rachel maddow said oh my gosh but
the reason that putin didn't attack
ukraine under trump was because trump's
position was aligned with
putin's or something like that moscow
yeah yeah with moscow of course they're
still selling that russian collusion
narrative right
to a certain degree though i don't think
she's she i think she's tactless but
there there's
one issue is the issue of nato i mean we
brought it up on the show that trump was
like why are we still in nato like
what's the purpose here and so putin was
like
okay like let's see what happens however
i do think in my opinion
i think trump was
too erratic
i don't think that vladimir putin was
like finally a president who's going to
work and for my favor no that makes no
sense because he was moving on ukraine
under obama he wanted crimea the eastern
the eastern regions had already declared
independence he waited until there was
someone weaker in office and i think the
re i think the issue is certainly maybe
you know it may be that
when when trump was questioning nato and
saying they should pay more putin was
like we'll see what happens
but that just seems like a stretch the
simpler answer is donald trump was
called a madman by his own followers by
his own fans they called him the madman
they called him the god emperor vladimir
putin's like
you've got to be careful with a man like
that he's erratic he could he could you
can't predict necessarily what he's
going to do now it doesn't mean that
putin is in a sense he's looking at a
reflection of himself
absolutely there's there there's a lot
of aspects about vladimir putin that are
very similar and you can't predict what
they're going to do they're extremely
hard-headed individuals
um you know and and again it's not it's
not do you like it do you not like it
it's what what keeps the wolves at bay
how much you want to bet you see that's
that that statement from joe biden about
a minor incursion remember that yeah
they were like what do you do if russia
invasions it depends on whether it's a
minor incursion or not you know i'll see
what we'll do and then everyone's like
he's basically saying the u.s is a
tolerance level for a russian invasion
of ukraine and then biden was like
that's their line i can push it a little
bit
i can't believe let me let's let's pull
this map real quick from nbc putin
pushed yeah yeah what did i say
oh yeah push and push down
no biden the only thing he pushes is
wheelchairs he's going to suddenly go to
sleep
i want to help
check out this map
they hid everywhere i mean this is crazy
yeah uh through belarus it's it's
absolutely insane comprehensive and this
map isn't even is an even comprehensive
it's leviv is not even on this map so
you know i was talking to my friend from
uh from kiev and she was just telling me
like all of these cities that were hit
so what it may be is that russians
russia's got special forces or some you
know some kind of uh you know ground
troops who had already infiltrated kiev
and then staged these low tier attacks
to cause widespread chaos confusion and
panic it seems to be sounds right
there's a lot of russian sentiment in
ukraine from what i've heard would have
been learning about i mean it used to be
part of the soviet union and a lot of
people in the soviet union felt a lot of
kinship towards russia and
you know it all kind of spawned from
russia in the beginning um the russian
revolution and so on you guys ready to
get madder than you've ever been
yeah oh okay i'm looking at it already
why don't you why don't you read that
headline ian
you want me to take the first line
you go all the way by the administration
asks cbp officers to leave southern
border for ukraine according to new
memory
you have got to be kidding me
this is this is the type of stuff that
that
makes me want to go crazy because
it makes you why first of all
how
you look at that headline and you can't
even begin to wrap your head around it
we don't even have enough people at the
southern border this has been an issue
for what a year now
and you're pulling them to go to ukraine
or asking volunteers and and it's and
it's because they want so it's it's
mostly poland they want they want these
troops in poland processing uh ukraine
refugees or migrants it's just
let me read a little bit they say
the bible administration is asking cbp
officers to voluntarily deploy to poland
following russia's invasion of ukraine
after being selected volunteers will
deploy within two or three days and work
in europe for at least one month
they say the off the office of field
operations is seeking volunteers to
assist with the possible evacuation of
u.s citizens lawful permanent residents
and their immediate family members in
ukraine it reads a memo sent to the
agency's field operations executives and
obtained by just the news so i don't
want to immediately be like oh you know
shake my fist we got to get americans
out of ukraine we got to get permanent
residents we got to get you know anyone
who's helping us we cannot let this be
another afghanistan foreign do we need
the border patrol here in america doing
that job to leave the already in
shambles southern border i feel like we
have plenty aspects of our military that
could cover that job absolutely you know
i i think i think military police could
probably do that um
just to name a few and i i i i'd like to
to present you with my vision of how
this came about
and and
so you've got joe biden and kamala
harris and they're in a room
and someone comes in you know and
they're like mr president the situation
in ukraine is very serious we're going
to need personnel to evacuate american
citizens permanent permanent residents
and biden goes oh oh oh no oh we have to
open the southern border now because cbp
is the only one who can do it and
they're like no mr president we don't
have to oh oh jeez you forced my hand
all right send cbp off the border and
send them to ukraine the only people
that understand borders is the border
patrol
i was thinking yesterday i actually
tweeted it out if we a war with russia
is actually a war with russia and china
and if that happened we wouldn't be
complaining about china invading taiwan
we'd be complaining about them invading
our southern border through mexico do
not eff around with this
uh
can we coin the term for like the russia
china alliance you know because like
history will remember the name of the
they're going to call them like you know
like the axes of evil or something
sino-rus
how about like the the the um
the evil avengers i can't even bring
myself to call my team to call them evil
like the good and evil narrative is
broken down we've been america's been
putting weapons and military bases in
people's face for a hundred years this
is insane and then they invade iraq this
is the country of freedom the one that
liberated cuba from the spanish empire
and gave it autonomy and independence we
fought a war to give cuba independence
not to conquer it and then we go into
iraq and afghanistan we give the rest of
the world carp blanche you can't sit in
a country and let the government conquer
say nothing and not expect other
countries to start conquering we are the
example
so it's it's it's it's all the same it's
propaganda the us and afghanistan the
u.s in iraq and then they go oh i can't
believe that uh russia would invade
ukraine get out of iraq
get out of iraq right now get out man
get out and do it safely god get out
this is what i tweeted and it was it was
a multi-faceted tweet i said i'm gonna
start an organization called anti-war
and we're we're going to claim to oppose
war but we'll actively support any war
that we're engaged in because we're
engaged in a war for the sake of
stopping war so our war is justified and
then everyone was like you're describing
the united states and antifa at the same
time and i'm like yeah yeah
like
the us is uh justified and engaging in
its conflicts
you know what you know what the issue is
it's the same players pointing their
fingers at each other over and over
again i mean who was in afghanistan
before we were it was the russians the
soviet union
it's back and forth and back and forth
and and
when you're when you're playing that
game it har it's hard to point the
finger because we we don't have any
right to say anything because we we've
been invading territories
for our own reasons we had we had
weapons of mass destruction was the
first reason that turned out to be a big
lie and then next thing you know we're
in how many countries in the middle east
you know and then we're pulling out
recklessly and and then you want to
point your finger and it's it's not to
say that that what putin is doing is
right it's not but
we can't be
the moral high ground of the world if we
don't have a moral high ground to stand
on
yeah uh so you know when people are
talking about why we should not get
involved in ukraine
i comply i agree i'm like we shouldn't
you know to a certain extent we can be
we obviously have to protect uh our
allies in in the baltic states to a
certain degree i don't even know how
much we want to get involved in that if
things you know truly go south because
not even our border but we do have
allies the challenge though i think is
it may be inevitable
whether whether we want to or not you
look at what happens in world war ii
eventually you get dragged into it now
yeah
you could ignore it you know you could
say okay well we're not getting involved
in ukraine but what happens when ukraine
falls
and that russia moves what does putin do
next
you know so
we poland's not going to be sitting
they're not going to be happy about that
yeah we've become entangled in all these
relationships because we wanted to go
out and be the world police we wanted to
go out and put all these weapons
facilities all over the world and you
know spread spread freedom by force
and look where it gets us you know how
how much better off is the american
public over the past 60 70 years that
we've adopted this world police sort of
mentality you know what has it done for
the average american citizen yeah quote
unquote it's guaranteed our safety but
you know you can't even measure that you
can't measure what you've actually
stopped i don't feel very safe right now
but the the what is the cost of the
average american citizen we have what 30
trillion dollars in debt how much how
much of that is war debt
you know from from us being the world
police from us funding nato from us
funding all these alliances and acting
like we're supposed to be
you know regulating everybody's behavior
around the world it's it's a novel or
excuse me it's it's a noble cause but
how how successful have we been and at
what cost nobody nobody wants to be the
one to back down you know uh
when i was when i talk about say antifa
and the woke far left actually i'll i'll
i'll i'll present you the the conundrum
the culture wars rap is rampaging on
would you be willing to give up free
speech and the first and second
amendments to have peace with antifa
that's a good question like i i say
antifa but you know the far left of
course not never there's no compromise
there that is even even if it would come
at peace because it's it's it's peace it
will cost kind of deal because what what
comes after that piece and so what
happens with a country like ukraine is
people you know they say things like we
should just not have the war you need to
like we should do and it's like i know
it's
yes we don't want war and it's really
easy to say but you've got russia
vladimir putin looks at what's going on
there and he says
i will not tolerate the us coming in and
i mean you look at what happened it's
not even it's not it's the west it's
nato it's eu you look what happened in
2014 with the protest there with
yanukovych putin views ukraine as
already conquered by the us yanukovych
was ousted
pro uh pro-america politicians get get
get put in
pro-west politicians and then he's like
i'm not gonna tolerate that's a red line
for me so he says we're gonna go in and
we're gonna we're gonna get rid of this
at western influence the united states
says the exact same thing about russia
vladimir putin wants to rebuild the
soviet union he's trying to build up the
russian trade federation he wants
ukraine as well we're battling over
ukraine and the question as with
yanukovych was you know who's he going
to side with where's the country going
to go
neither side is willing to give up that
territory the bread basket of europe
thus you get war now let me just throw
it back to the original we're no better
off than we were 70 years ago 80 years
ago during the cold war right we're
right back in that same scenario but
let's let's throw it to to this this the
start of the segment and to what i think
matters substantially more
when you have the bite administration
asking cbp officers to leave our
southern border
they do not care about this country
right and they are asking the united
states of america to sacrifice blood and
treasure
for for people in a far away land this
is sorry go ahead i was going to say i i
i
shouldn't we secure our own oxygen could
you imagine being one of the first
people that volunteered to go to vietnam
because you didn't know what what was
actually coming waiting for you over
there yeah those people like the people
volunteered happily in the beginning
because they didn't realize because they
bought all the propaganda lydia i'm
sorry i felt like i interrupted you i
was just gonna say this to me seems like
such insult to injury for joe biden to
stand up there and say we're gonna have
to make sacrifices who's really making
sacrifices here is it joe biden the
middle class it's my middle class and
only in the middle class yeah i mean but
none of that it's the it's the poverty
like middle class and down yeah when i
say when i say middle class i mean
everybody because to us or to that to
them it's it's everybody except them
look at look at these like blue check
elites who are like we have to intervene
it's like i've got an application right
here for you to sign up yeah how old are
you you're 55 well if you could hold a
gun i thought you asked a really
interesting question what's putin going
to do next and that's like i've been
thinking a lot this came up a couple
days ago and was worth repeating that
when hitler invaded poland he was doing
it in his he said because they were
after world war one the treaty of
versailles split a piece of germany off
gave it to poland and then the polish
government was executing and creating
committing genocide on these former
germans now polish so hitler was going
to liberate that area and bring peace
back to those germans putin's saying a
similar thing with uh ukraine
post-soviet they're russian um there's a
genocide going on he actually said that
in his declaration uh yesterday
i don't know if there's a genocide going
on the the us news has been completely
silent i've never heard an inkling that
there might be a genocide going on in
ukraine it's different it's not out of
the realm of possibility no no it's
different i would i would say i think
the ukrainians learn their lesson about
russian control from the hall of demore
and probably are not too keen to be you
know involved in something like that but
when we're if we're drawing parallels
russia doesn't need to be germany in
this china can be
it's it's you know history doesn't
repeat it right right because china does
have muslimy and hitler kind of fed off
each other one would invade a little bit
then the other one be like oh okay i
guess that means it's okay for me to
take and they're like really well then
i'm gonna take a little bit more here
then i'll go into poland here so if the
russians take a little piece the chinese
psychotic racist han supremacist
mentality might because putin's not a
psychotic racist hitler was but the ccp
they strike me as psychotic racists well
they got the uyghur muslims in
concentration this is also american
propaganda i'm getting this fed to me
from the americans but that's what it
seems like it's not just the americans
reporting on what's happening with the
weaker muslims and you've also got that
that's an established fact that that i
mean that's like open massacre on these
people so yeah you know we're we're not
without sin but you know i think there's
uh there's a certain level of sinister
behavior that's going on uh with within
the chinese government that is is beyond
you know what we're talking about
everybody else let me let me jump to
this story from newsweek because this is
is relevant
newsweek reports u.s expects kiev to
fall in days as ukraine's source warns
of encirclement so you've got multiple
reporters on the story saying um three
different u.s officials ukraine's
capital will fall within i think they
say 96 hours and within a week the
ukrainian government will fall to russia
this bad
it's very bad however
it could be
better than the alternative
ukraine falling could be an end to the
conflict outright
sure yeah i mean but we we
these situations are are are terrible
because they're incredibly complex and
you don't know the next moves of of of
some of these people you know what
happens when ukraine falls is is putin
satisfied that's a great question you
know this is my next question is he
satisfied or
you know and and do we just
if he is satisfied do we just take that
loss
yeah you know and and what are the
repercussions of that you know i mean
walking away with america
what are we worried about now the issue
is
nato these these western european
nations want cheaper energy
russia controls a lot of the energy
flowing in
the craziest thing is one of one one of
the moves that joe biden made uh in the
past couple of days was to sanction the
nord stream to pipeline which goes from
russia to germany
he sanctioned that
but he was the one who lifted the
sanctions on in the first place they
tried to appease after he shut down the
keys
exactly they tried to appease russia it
didn't work
russia
vladimir putin sees the appeasement
they're like okay we're going to lift
these sanctions you can do your pipeline
just don't invade ukraine otherwise
we'll put them back in place and putin
went oh yeah sure because we were fine
with those sanctions yep you know that
they weren't affecting them that greatly
so he said okay sure
ben shapiro made a really really great
point he said uh paraphrasing
that the u.s
that our our culture is so materialistic
yes that we think sanctions inhibiting
their ability to buy things will stop
them russia wants to rebuild the russian
empire china johnson today joe biden
said it today that he didn't think the
sanctions were going to do anything
there's a clip of him coming out and
saying yeah well we didn't think
sanctions were going to do anything
anyway
you know so it's it's a it's it's all
for show
he know he knows that that's not going
to be enough of a deterrent ben shapiro
made the really interesting point sorry
to catch you off i just had to throw
this out there but ben shapiro made the
really interesting point that russia has
something higher to work for that the
u.s no longer has he's like we are so
materialistic we care about faster cars
we care about levi's we don't actually
care about our country or like any kind
of overarching moral framework and they
do and that's something we can they've
been struggling for how long right you
know and this is this is
if you're if you're russian you know and
if you're in the russian government and
if you're vladimir putin you're seeing
this as a chance to you know like you
said rebuild or or restore whatever that
empire was in his mind i think and we're
not looking at it from that perspective
right we've in america we've never
experienced that you know the worst
hardship that we've experienced
financially in terms of in terms of you
know hardship was the depression and we
made it out of that okay and that that
elapsed far into our memories you know
these people have been living
under harsh conditions for a really long
time so they're looking they're looking
at these opportunities to
capitalize and become a more powerful
country become more economically stable
you know so
what dog do we have in the fight here
i think if he was smart putin he is that
he would take what he takes out of
ukraine and then that's it he moves on
and he's remembered as vladimir the
great like you could
but if he pushes you
honestly do you if you were a betting
man would you bet that he would do that
no i wouldn't yeah because otherwise
he's going to get the world declare war
on him he's got to be careful no no i i
think i think you know we learned a
little bit at a time we learned a lesson
here just two days ago we're like ah he
won't go for kia that's ridiculous he
won't go
96 hours yeah yeah yeah we we we were
sitting here saying it'll never happen
and then last night it's like the show
ends and i got a message from luke and
he's like all caps during the show too
yeah
russia's invaded and i'm like well then
yeah we were hard and fast because if he
took a little bit now and then waited
and later tried went for kiev it'd be a
big deal now he's just taking it all at
once to get it out get it over with
before people from the looks of the map
it looks like the entire country yeah
he's gonna take the whole thing and then
it's gonna be done and it's gonna be
russia
why would he stop
because the world will declare war on
them no they won't i think they will
he's already so you have no choice yeah
yeah who the united states britain
france germany
um all these people that are relying on
cheap energy turkey probably will get
this is the chinese will be on the
russian side absolute torture for
everybody it's this entanglement of
everybody's interests you know you have
you have europe relying on russia for a
tremendous amount of cheap energy are
they going to be so quick to declare war
well this is the crazy thing the the
idea for so long was that trade would
stop war it's what the neocons and
neo-liberal establishment thought they
were going to do they said we'd do a
free trade agreement with china and then
we'll have peace because no one will
want to go to war instead what happens
is the bully in the room says i'll go to
war and i get your stuff and ain't
nothing you can do about it yep yeah
it works a little true but it doesn't
stop war
it helps get people get to know each
other but that's it gives you an
incentive to work together but it
doesn't stop conflict no it doesn't
because there's always workarounds in a
global economy there's always
workarounds you can slap russia with
sanctions but guess what when china has
their back how much do those sanctions
actually mean yeah like if they get
kicked off the swift payment system did
that we already touch on that story no
we're going to go next in a second yeah
that's i mean that's
talk about a new banking
regime but i i i think
right now you've got germany they didn't
want the sanctions on uh nordstrom too
because they want the gas they want the
energy they need it yeah now they have
no choice because vladimir putin's like
i literally don't care i got you by the
balls if you need our gas we can take
what we want it's one of the reasons the
us was like hey we should be working
with our western allies to move this
pipeline up from you know the cutter
turkey pipeline through syria but all of
that does all that does
if vladimir putin has control over your
energy and then you say we're going to
screw with your allies and build a
pipeline to shut your your monopoly on
energy down they're going to be like you
know i can see you doing that right
that's going to happen like putin's like
i'm watching you attack my interests i'm
not going to sit back and let you do i
used to play a lot of civilization and
in the game sometimes i would choose to
be like a trade heavy net uh country and
i'd have all these trade networks all
over the world but then every once in a
while the world would be like we're
going to take we're we're going to war
and as soon as the person would go
toward me all my trades would end
abruptly i'd be bankrupt i'd have no
income i'd have no
careers i'd have no leather i'd have no
basically if you're relying on trade and
you go to war with your trade partner
you're getting done yeah you're saying
you're bad at civilization is that what
it is well i learned the hard way i got
good the hard way
in civilization it's a video game is
energy independence no you take the furs
from them with guns well that's one
option if you're playing that kind of
i never play civilization that way yeah
i always i always have really strong
borders a really strong and advanced
military and i mind my own business it's
like a novelty
that is a novel concept
can you say that one more time for us
this is how i i isn't it you know this
is really funny though do you win a lot
when you play oh yeah every time but but
i go for science and cultural victory
which is there's different ways to win
so
you know i had a buddy and um he
introduced me to fallout 3.
so i'm playing fallout 3 if you ever
play fallout yeah game first so when i
whenever i play it you know what i go
for i go for stealth sniper
sneak lock pick so dangerous yeah that's
how i play the game i never get in any
direct conflicts i see a super mutant
i'm in the bushes and slow motion that's
gotta get some power armor
hold on my buddy
when he's playing the game
he runs in guns blazing heavy weapons
that's how i played metal gear
wait wait wait hold on check it out he
was a marine
yeah and so i'm like you know what like
the mentality of the person comes out
you know it's expressed in the way they
play these games his view was go in guns
are blazing shut it down quick and fast
and control the situation mine was sneak
around slowly take your time be patient
very different personalities when i play
civilization
you can see my mentality and all this
stuff i don't like war
mind my own business peace and
prosperity and that's how i play the
game
we i build up my my cities i make every
everyone live really great lives we do
we do we research and technology what do
you do and we mine our own business what
do you do if someone attacks you in the
game we wipe them out i i i
i go completely ballistic and wipe them
off the face of the earth like i don't i
don't just sue for peace i i eradicate
the species well well
in civilization if you do that all the
other countries and they think i'm a
warmonger but it's like you know what
you deserve it because you're a war you
attacked me that's a crazy mentality and
i'm afraid that humans have that
mentality look like real life i'm
playing a game i got my little country
you know the land my people have settled
they come to my borders and they say
give me your stuff and i say don't try
it don't try it they try it they get
crushed i go into their cities i occupy
them
and then whenever gets mad at me i say i
don't care stay the f away from my
borders leave me alone and you'll have
no problems
i i i like that mentality america can
have all the nukes in the world it can
be the most powerful mf on the planet
and it can sit back with its feet up and
be like dude we're chilling you guys
leave us alone and we're good that was
the original idea right that's until
they invented iraq or afghanistan yeah i
mean we got we got it wrong way before
we invaded hawaii i think i think it was
like woodrow wilson yeah it was before
we used to we colonized hawaii we
invaded hawaii and took it over from the
natives we invaded wake island and
midway island like we we were one of
those one of those conquistador
countries like with britain and france
and all them
yeah but the you know the original idea
was that we we set out to be
isolationists we we
we conquered obviously
from
c to c and then we said okay this is
this is our spot here now and
we're not gonna go
you know around the world but we're to
show it off you know they they sell they
sell the navy around the world
originally the great white fleet or
whatever i believe it was called
um
you know because to show off our might
but then it went back to our borders and
that's realistically that's that that
should be the purpose of a military you
know what would have enabled us to
maintain our isolationist policies would
have been to have developed some form of
energy independence because this is a
problem in germany they decided to shut
down their nuclear plants because they
had a whole lot of green guilt from a
little swedish girl and now they rely so
heavily on russian gas they can't live
without it they're literally talking
about blackouts and brownouts during the
winter in germany because they shut down
their nuclear power plants and they rely
so heavily and when they sanction russia
it is going to be a dark and cool
well freedom is about
self-dependence right if you if you
can't stand on your own two feet whether
that be uh at the level of a country or
all the way down to the individual you
can't be free unless you can tell
somebody to piss off and since that you
don't need them and that you'll do it
yourself yes and and we need to have
that as a if we're going to adopt that
mentality as a country we can't be
reliant upon china russia anybody for
energy we have to be able to stand on
our own two feet and say we're not
getting involved but if you come to our
borders you will find out
i got it's really troused by this if you
think nuclear energy is too dangerous
but you're willing to threaten a nuclear
war power for oil
for your energy you've missed the plot
you see the problem nuclear power is
less dangerous it's safer than attacking
russia i gotta know i gotta give we
gotta give an honorable mention to ian
for this next segment the guardian
reports kiev is furious as eu wavers on
banning russia from the swift payment
system now before we get into everything
i just want to point this out if you
guys
you know there's a lot of people they're
like oh world war iii it's clickbait
it's not going to happen
the swift payment system it's the
international monetary international
banking system ach payments bank
transfers it's how trade is done
if russia gets booted because this is
what's happening kiev is furious they
say we want it to happen but there are
members of eu like germany they're
saying we don't want to do it boris
johnson is saying do it boot russia from
swift this would mean russia can't use
banks anymore outside of the country it
cuts them off financially do you think
china says sorry russia can't help you
or do you think china says we'll
facilitate the trade for you do you
think russia says oh no i guess we've
lost and now everything is done or do
you think russia says you want a war
we'll give you one cutting them off from
the financial system
look
the only thing it will do is push russia
further away and give them less of a
reason to actually negotiate on any of
this stuff
and i see blue checks i see high profile
democrat personalities and and never
trump or neocon types being like yeah we
should do this yeah yeah shut it down
and i'm like okay give russia nothing
left to lose do it and then see how they
respond fortunately i'm from the
washington examiner 50 minutes ago biden
declines to cut russia from swift
payments no no that's from today's
sanctions there's going to be a meeting
i believe tomorrow so biden today
said we're only going to sanction some
of their biggest banks we we are not
going to be cutting them off from swift
this does not mean they won't in the
future
sounds like a baby step to me right
saying your four largest banks are being
cut off it's saying
be prepared we're gonna we're gonna shut
down your entire financial system coming
so crazy and then you see him shutting
off the bank accounts of the canadian
people the uh celinski the president of
ukraine has shut off three according to
tulsi gabbard three of the largest
television stations in prison like this
is western democracy doing these things
shutting up threatening to shut off
economies
we're not the good guys
maybe we're not the good guys war war
war ain't no thing no nobody's a good
guy
is not a walk in the park
during world war two we had an office of
censorship
the u.s had a department uh it was it
was a department of censorship who
slipped synchronization the germans had
the minister of propaganda goebbels yo
we had internment camps for the japanese
in the united states
the this idea i don't teach that too
often anymore no they they they they
browse right over that in in you know
u.s history one and two in high school
now they don't know what they're doing
camps yeah they not for me well now i
mean you know these days yeah i mean
history history class has gotten watered
down tremendously since you know since
the time that we were in school we
should know more i mean that's that's
something that's really important
because again it's it's if we are going
to be the country that says
you are wrong
you can't do this we need to start
working on
our best and like tim was saying in war
you know things how things change maybe
there was some value to in turning the
japanese that may have been japanese
spies who knows if we hadn't and turned
the japanese back that was the initial
overthrow that was the initial uh
reasoning for it but it was like
japanese citizens civilians like expats
people that didn't deserve to be
imprisoned were being in turn so there's
a lot of collateral damage when you do
something as sweeping as that so you you
talk a lot ian about the swift payment
system
tell me your ideas on the swift payment
system it's like a global i don't know
who created it or where exactly i
imagine it has to do with the bank of
international settlements in switzerland
but it's like a company it actually goes
through the bank of belgium wow like i
think like 11 000 banks
all right 11 000 banks 200 countries
around the world
and it moves through the bank of belgium
the society for worldwide interbank
financial telecommunication
swift it was founded in 1973 48 years
ago
la holt is that you pronounce it belgium
it handles basically uh all
i'm sorry it says uh
around half of all high-value
cross-border payments worldwide use the
swift network does it have any figure as
to the dollar amount of the transactions
that go through that type of it says 30.
it's staggering 32 million messages per
day
so
transactions a transaction
i i would imagine a million okay so
that's that you're talking an
unconceivable amount of money probably
and it's probably dark money too i bet a
lot of that's under the table that's the
problem with the bank of international
settlements in switzerland where they
kind of funnel money through as there's
no oversight no governmental oversight
in the world it's a private company
that's controlling this
economy basically right now so i have i
have a
maybe maybe you'll have some thoughts on
this right so say we do
kick them out
right we kick them out of swift
where does the crypto market come into
that oh maybe they'll probably make like
a bomb today yeah they'll probably make
it their national currency a crypto
they'll probably create like one or or
use bitcoin or or that's an interesting
what what happens with the crypto market
then when an entire country says all
right you'll kick me off of you know
your your traditional standard
um you know transaction system well we
have crypto that's right and
you can't shut that down you can't
russia can just very easily say
we're going to now unless you shut off
their their internet in the entire
country i guess would be the that was
the threat
the threat and again look how quickly
that escalates
you know that
you could you could replace you could
replace the banking ledger with the
crypto ledger
you could say here's how we're going to
do i mean i'm sure russia's already
working on it russia's bought up bitcoin
they're probably saying why should we
rely on the centralized controlled
payment system out of out of out of
western europe
we can just use decentralized crypto to
facilitate value exchanges and then have
that be the basis for our monetary
system in our own country and again you
have
talking from a crypto standpoint you
know i i have a
a very novice level of understanding of
crypto but okay they say okay we're
going to adopt crypto and then what
happens when the entire russian economy
switches to mining crypto they have the
space for it they have the resources
you know they could do it up in those
really cold siberian places where it
keeps the gpus colder we're in an
interesting place in crypto where we're
moving away from proof of work to create
the crypto and it's moving towards proof
of stake so like the people that are
rich are going to get more rich but the
people that are are creating it are not
really going to be the ones that make
money on it anymore it's kind of it's
kind of lame that they're doing that but
it's like a rich man well it's what
happens when government gets starts
getting involved in these things you
know crypto was at least from my
understanding the uh the
the separation between government
oversight and regulation and money and
now we're watching governments adopt it
when i when i saw we're going to pro we
may provoke in
one of the world's largest countries to
adopt them it may be inevitable actually
i wonder if that i was thinking the
bastion of freedom united states that's
now invaded and enslaved iraqis for 20
years it would be the the pressure that
would push a country to
develop some sort of more free equitable
currency when when i saw the news
about you know ukraine saying we want
them banned from from swift uh uh kiev
said we want a ban from swift when i saw
boris johnson saying it i immediately
bought bitcoin immediately that's just
me i'm not giving anybody advice i
bought it and then right after i did i
was in the dip because it dropped when
the chaos happened and then spiked again
and i was in the dip and it spiked and i
was like all right that's good for me i
guess but you know what i'm thinking
if they do ban look they're already
sanctioning these banks
these banks can already circumvent that
by using bitcoin right now yeah so what
does that say sanctions are meaningless
but if they kick them off swift
i think bitcoin through the roof
because russia is going to be like buy
it up and what does china do at that
point buy it up oh yeah after after
they've already taken this hard stance
against you know kind of crypto and but
they you can trust people i guess i
guess they've they've taken a hard
stance against people owning crypto but
they i'm sure they have no problem
buying it up themselves no they they do
that as a game they they they put out
these bans so they can strike the price
down because people panic then they can
buy it back up
you know what might happen i don't know
if it will
we kick russia off swift russia says
we're going to use bitcoin to back our
transactions and handle our
international trade china says hey
russia we're in it with you we want your
help on taiwan both russia and china
don't like the petro dollar anyway they
say okay you don't want to trade oil you
don't want us to get access to your
markets we're going to cut you off from
our energy production and we're going to
buy in crypto or bitcoin or other
currencies you can't do nothing about it
at this point it could precipitate the
end of the of the us dollar
absolutely at a
i mean we're we're watching it like
slowly kind of like just decline at this
point but that would that would be an
over
night
just
death to the dollar not to mention gas
prices already skyrocketing
what are they saying four bucks a gallon
is coming yeah because not getting close
now with the sanctions of the conflict
russia is going to be pushing back being
like you don't get our oil if we can't
trade on your systems we don't we don't
give you the oil we're going to keep it
for ourselves and i bet you joe biden
doesn't even consider opening our
national pipelines oh no he's shutting
him down there was a he recently
recently there was news um i should try
i'll try and find in a second
recently issued a ban on on on producing
natural gas in the united states another
one why
i don't know man a little swedish girl
why why
cbp from our southern border to go to
poland
the policy is it is to gut this country
either because they're morons or they're
laughing all the way down
it's got to be i believe the latter i
really i really do at this point you
can't be
you know you hear people all the time oh
joe bud and he's so stupid and you know
come on i don't believe these people are
that stupid you don't get to that
position in life being an idiot
he's good at following orders that's for
sure
sure
but
you can't be making this many mistakes
they've made too many mistakes at this
point for it to be stupidity yeah i
think you're you're gutting this country
from the inside i think corporations
including the federal like the oh
reunion just take it one issue at a time
look at the southern border and work
your way up from there what comes across
the southern border illegals you know
people
nobody vetted fentanyl the number one
killer of the ages between what 18 and
35 right now is fentanyl where does that
come from comes from china you know look
at our supply chain look at our energy
production look at the value of our
dollar all of these things are moving in
the wrong direction and they're they are
all the result of
policy created by our own government
these aren't none of these things are
happening to us because of outside
influence i wonder if yeah sure china is
shipping drugs but we have a
responsibility to protect our own border
we're not doing any of these things and
all of the problems that we're facing
today as a as a society as an american
society are self-inflicted by our own
government moving moving border agents
to poland when we have a clear
crisis at the border is about the
stupidest thing i've ever heard how
about this one for you from
americanpress.com biden halts all new
oil and gas leases from wednesday
february 23rd 2022 reported by the ap
the bind administration is delaying
decisions on all new oil and gas
drilling on federal land and other
energy related actions after a federal
court blocked the way officials were
calculating the real world cost of
climate change what were you just you're
saying the green green guilt
it's a high it's a hijacked idea you
know and
nobody i don't think at this point
denies the fact that humans have an
influence on the on the climate around
them right but this idea that we that
everything we do has to be like
renewable and this and that it's a it's
a ruse
to undermine all of these things
that make us fiercely independent this
country can depend on itself we we have
everything that we're we're one we're a
unique country right we have everything
that we need within our borders to be
completely self-reliant and somehow we
are not i think we are
we're on the verge of alaska
we are we are facing down full-scale
ground war in europe like there is
legitimately a groundwork in europe
right now the most
significant halting oil since world war
ii
and biden's like
oil and gas we don't need it that should
be something he rubber stamps at this
point yeah until further notice yeah we
have we have a conflict on the horizon
ramp up the machines at home and get
ready
to at least at the very least flex your
muscles
biden's going to look i'm going to look
at joe biden flexing his muscles and
laugh at this point
excuse me
i got to say my body might be looking in
the mirror
i got to say something that's probably
controversial oh yeah um you know and
it's going to make a lot of people angry
no but donald trump was a better
president than what joe biden but there
are no tweets that's right
yeah i thought about it i thought about
it and i was thinking um
maybe the mean tweets were worth it
maybe it was yeah yeah yeah
energy independence there there are a
lot of things that i disagree with
donald trump on but he is unequivocally
a better and stronger and i think
stronger is is really
in terms of this topic an important
characteristic yeah he is a stronger
president he projects strength in a way
that joe biden i don't think ever could
but nor kamal harris or nor really
anybody on that roster on that side but
i i gotta get a little real with it it's
not hard to be better than joe biden
right now no no no we're not setting the
bar extremely right
i thought trump was great about not
falling for this kind of global agenda
of corporatization like he got us out of
the trans-pacific partnership within
like two weeks of coming into office he
saw the danger of allowing our citizens
to be sued by corporations because they
didn't want to discriminate they didn't
want to buy malaysian oil like
we're sovereign citizens we don't have
to bow to a corporation that was early
on world economic forum stuff um and
i think that what's happening is that
there are corporate powers that are
putting countries against each other so
that they fight and then they can fall
apart and be like hey see national
governments don't work anymore let us
come in and say i told you guys this
before the show let us come in and save
you with our corporate benevolence yeah
i just wanted
i want to follow this story from the ap
hyden halts oil gas leases amid legal
fight on climate costs
russia just invaded and this is february
22nd when they were screaming russia was
going to invade kiev we're talking about
climate cost and he was like well you
know that that little swedish girl
yelled at me so i think
cut off the power oh my god i just i'm
flabbergasted
and again for this man even with this
stuff
what what
beyond the headline because it sound it
sounds nice to your you know to your
bleeding heart you know social justice
warrior what does climate cost actually
mean we don't know in in
in that discussion
i think the assumption is that carbon
too much carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere is going to cause a
greenhouse effect which is going to
cause superheating but so we should be
worried that's the worry we should be
worried about the shorelines
disappearing more than we should about
a possible european invasion from russia
like that that's the calculus potential
invasions are preeminent in in the
forefront i think but
you should not be focusing on
how bad things could get but how to fix
the problem which is the carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere you got it i just got
to step in and say
we've got the potential for total
nuclear annihilation in the immediate
order but we're looking at that clock
environmental danger a nuclear bomb
going off the atmosphere
exactly it's like it's 10 million years
of this stuff that those two words are
are essentially meaningless climate cost
it's
i'm i'm meaningless
you know the american military is like
the biggest polluter in the world the
amount of crap it dumps into the oceans
with its navy is and its army is like it
as a court if it was a corporation it
would be the largest polluter on earth
i'm sure it probably is and and we're
we're not even high we're not even up
there on the list of of
the people that we're talking about in
this discussion russia china all these
are are polluters of the world these are
people who don't buy this climate crop
you know cost nonsense and and granted
china does a lot of things wrong there's
there's no uh acceptance of the way that
they do things coming from me but
we are worrying about climate cost when
these people are worrying about taking
over entire countries this is it's like
what ben shapiro was saying we're like
we're going to sanction you and then you
can't use the bank and putin's like i
want to rebuild the empire and i'll kill
anyone to get my way exactly we're not
even having the same destruction but you
can't buy that sill first we want to
make sure there's a bow on it before you
do it and he's like smashes the wall out
of the way and it's like come on i saw
this build a wall i saw this i saw this
story the other day
and i'm like
my immediate thought process was shut
down the show
shut down all the work we're doing tim
cass is over i'm gonna go bu i'm gonna
go buy a coconut sit back put the
sunglasses on put my feet up and be like
it was fun while it lasted
it's time it's time to milk as much time
as we got left because baby we are we
are going downhill from here this this
is i mean this is absurd our priorities
are and again it's not to say that these
things are not important because i'm not
i'm not one to just you know just spit
into the wind because that's what you're
doing when you're ignoring
uh the effects that you do have on the
climate however we need to have some
prioritization of of what is important
and what is not important and and where
we've got it
seemingly completely upside down people
are going to vote for the democrats just
i'm just in november there's gonna be a
midterm and it's gonna be close the
democrats could even win
i just i just not andy kim if if you if
you show this article to someone and
you're like russia invaded ukraine biden
decides to stop producing oil and gas
i'm just
how are you the party of vladimir putin
is an existential threat and trump was
colluding with them and also and also
let's shut down our energy production
it's like the people who are like we
don't like the government has all the
guns let's ban all the guns yeah except
for the government right except for the
yeah exactly well that's i'm just i'm so
right it's kind of par for the course at
this point you know coming coming from
that side
you know it's it's the it's the
the movement of doublethink and mental
gymnastics because somehow to these
people when they go to the ballot box it
it makes sense to them i'm going to buy
a machete and a bunch of coconuts and
i'm going to sit downstairs and i'm just
going to machete open those coconuts and
drop a straw in there and be like i'm
i'm done well before you do that i have
to say i will i will say that i've not
seen the term climate cost before and
that is really interesting to me because
it is super vague it strikes me a little
bit how's that calculated it strikes me
as anti-racism this is one of the
nebulous goals that black lives matter
is fighting for what is climate cost
when we know if we achieve this goal
what is the goal i don't think is there
an equation the opportunity cost of loss
of like the climate getting hotter
calculating this yeah exactly and
they're linear calculations they're not
accounting for change in the the the
progression so if you develop a new
technology that can recover the carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere and turn it
into graphene it dramatically changes
the direction of our of our models and i
think it's been it's been clearly shown
at least to my understanding that
of all the things that we can factor in
to to climate cost and climate change
we're we're we're only
you know accounting for a quarter of of
the things that actually come into play
so
this equation that we're that we're
basing
domestic policy on is
not a very good one yeah an asteroid
could completely annihilate the surface
yeah that's climate change yeah it's
just it's you know it again you you have
to prioritize and this is this is this
is pure
uh this is this is par for the course of
what we're seeing you know what what do
we prioritize at home we're prioritizing
you know all of these ludicrous agendas
meanwhile our country is legitimately
falling apart from the inside
i can't imagine that uh the u.s can
survive something as insane as this
i mean we're talking about our energy
infrastructure and we're not just
talking about that we're talking about
that plus war
when you're a country that cannot put
aside
you know long-term climate goals
to deal with
present emergencies existential crises
you're doomed
i mean it's it's like
the united states is looking at russia
and they're like we would rather die
than pollute the the air that's
essentially then you will that's that's
essentially what that headline reads
yeah
it is so it is so strange to me that
people who can't ever think past stage
one are now thinking so far into the
future that they can't look at an actual
possible nuclear war and be like oh
maybe we should put this on the back
burner for maybe a month or two while we
can figure it a while yeah just like an
actual just turn them on until we get
this situation under control and then we
can resume that
less important discussion i can't
believe that yo
i don't know man what's going to happen
aliens are going to invade yes please
force save us oh yeah i think save us
the solution is meditation is is prayer
and meditation i don't know i heard
thoughts for ukraine
prayers for ukraine yeah and then and
then silent mind you do the prayer of
healthy or whatever you want to pray and
then
absence of thought for as long as you
want alex jones told me that if if you
uh you do dmt you can speak to the
machine elves who will grant you the
secrets to the universe so let's do it
maybe they're gonna help save all of us
from things because
i'm trying to find a conventional way to
fix and it just keeps getting worse and
worse and worse and worse and infected
and more black mold and like right it's
got to be some psychoactive solution no
there's there's rumors already
that they've already been shuffling off
shuttling out prominent high-profile
political figures into bunkers now i
don't know if that's true or not but in
ukraine no no in the united states okay
yeah i i i don't know doe ran away from
truckers so uh maybe yeah they're
surprised perhaps but there's there's
rumors going around that some flights
have left and they're going to areas
with underground bunkers i don't know if
it's true maybe it's not i hope it's
true if we're if we're literally on the
verge of potential chaos we need our
well our political fleet is happening do
we
i know i hate saying that but yeah we
high profile individuals getting ready
for for war and no if our leaders aren't
going to bonkers is a good thing you
don't want your king standing out in the
field just like waving like i'm the king
i'm in charge here i wouldn't mind joe
biden standing out in the middle of the
field right now at this point i was
wondering is kamala harris a more
competent leader
could you imagine joe biden on horseback
like needing a charge
no can't that'd be cool he wouldn't be
able to get up that'd be wild they tie
him to the horse they used to do that i
got a weekend at bernie sanders
i got to do this you guys i got it i got
i have to talk about this man's house oh
the garbage yes the garbage garbage i
have to talk to you about a man named
jenk yuger of the young turks and i
don't want to because he's just a pundit
but when we're dealing with an internal
conflict that is effectively an
existential threat you need to
understand the sentiment that exists
among
some of these individuals on the
establishment side jankuger tweets
right wing doesn't love putin just
because he is an authoritarian
tyrannical leader they love him because
he's a white authoritarian leader race
has become more important than even
nationality they've turned on democ on
democracy and now even america in favor
of a white warlord
this may be one of the most insane
things i've ever read
nowhere in these incoherent ramblings
was there even a semblance of a thought
yet this man has millions of followers
and does
actually have influence over a large
portion of the political discourse in
this country
joe biden
is an old white man yep who
is is leading the empire of the united
states according to the young turks
themselves and many of the left the us
is the empire is the fascist empire so
is joe biden not a white tyrannical
authoritarian apparently not apparently
it's putin but please show me
where right-wing individuals are
cheering for what putin is doing nowhere
jake yeuger highlights tucker carlson
saying it proves him right because
tucker explained what putin's mentality
was that's it and i think that's
important to understand right is it not
it is yeah when when dealing when
dealing with who is
right now your enemy is it not good to
understand the mentality that they have
it's necessary to perhaps come to some
sort of solution
yeah you know absolutely they don't want
it it's it's this typical rhetoric today
where you don't even attempt to
understand the other side you just you
just declare that they are wrong
and and hate them yeah i would like to
to understand putin's side i think i
don't i'm not like yay i wish he was my
leader but i under he's a i think as a
general goes if i was like playing a
video game and i wanted to put a guy in
command of my military i'd pick him over
biden or xi jinping who are both
bureaucrats this guy's got like military
experience he's xkgb he's cold as ice he
doesn't show emotion on his face he's a
good commander now ethically that's a
whole other discussion and we have
different russia and the united states
come from different places and we have
different ethics and morals um
that's another conversation but i have
that appreciation for the guy that for
his abilities but but just bringing it
back to what the u.s is facing but it's
not because he's white and that what
chank younger said is completely racist
it's not just that it i don't care what
there's no substance here it doesn't
matter
the ideas he's trying to convey what
matters is that
i i i he he's just not well okay he's
not well it's it's white people
attacking white really disturbing you
know it's what does this have to do with
race this is this is typical again
talking about priorities of of the you
know of the american mindset
this is what we're worried about we're
worried about white authoritarian
leaders how about just the fact that
people are dying the young turks was a
genocidal group of turks in the early
1900s led by enverpasha that basically
created the armenian genocide it's
basically they did why would he name his
company the young turks
changed the name yeah check dude why i
just want to know why it's a cool
sounding name i said listen it's because
look man
i don't want to be overly reductive
here's a guy spouting that they love
putin i i certainly don't love putin i
don't know but mate so so you know i'm
not going to assume he's talking about
me i'm that right wing right no i'm
talking about me he calls me right-wing
calls me right wing whenever they do
segments about me certainly whatever
that means fine but to imply that i am
involved in any kind of love for putin
is psychotic
jank yuger doesn't i don't think he
reads
i don't think he pays attention and i
think he actually look i'm gonna come
out and say it
he named his organization the young
turks
a genocidal group of people
he even denied the existence of the
armenian genocide until until i think
like 10 years ago or something like that
so even while he had the young turkeys
like it never happened or something like
that and then he apologizes for it i
can't respect the apology for 100.
bro change the name of your organization
it's like a and this is something that
comes up all the time but this dude has
the nerve to come out and claim the
right loves putin because he's an
authoritarian trinical leader dude
literally names his organization after
people who carried a genocide and
refuses refuses to change its name
dude don't get your moral lessons from
these people this tweet should be enough
to know this dudes lost his mind and
this is coming from the authoritarian
left i mean
these are the same people that champion
antifa you know and and and exactly it's
such cognitive dissonance they're
talking about authoritarian leaders what
have we been experiencing over the past
two years with mandates
these people have championed you know
rule by mandate sort of governance rule
by decree rule by decree
is he does he support that i haven't
really followed that i yeah he doesn't
talk
i would go ahead well i i would go ahead
and bet heavily i would do yeah i would
go ahead and bet heavily that he was
pro-lockdown uh that he was probably pro
uh vaccine mandate
um and all of the and if i'm if i'm
wrong correct me um but coming from that
portion of the left these are people
that love
love big government look at look at this
when it caters to them you know look i i
hate to talk about him because he needs
his kind of attention he doesn't he
doesn't nearly get as much attention as
he used to whatever
he says i'm sure the fake left in
america tulsi gabbard etc who are still
pretending to be progressive are livid
about this attack on civil rights let
alone putin's unmitigated imperialism
i'm sure those pundits and award-winning
journalists are speaking out forcefully
right
yes
russia arresting protesters is wrong 100
what world does this man live in or his
followers that they think the right
likes putin because he's a white
tyrannical leader and that they're happy
he's arresting people this is a
fabricated reality that doesn't exist
yeah where where where's the evidence
that that that thought even has been put
out there by anybody credible that
represents
yeah they're right i really don't like
assumptions in general yeah i mean
that's just one of those things where
it's like at least show me a tweet from
somebody who's got as many followers as
you do that has that has said like yeah
putin go get um
exactly it's
i mean it's these people love creating
enemies where there there is none and
and boogeyman's where there are none
it's
the weird thing is it's like these
pieces of these people it chank changed
it didn't used to be he's same guy but
different behavior he used to be real
anti-war and really like talking about
right now he'd be talking about iraq if
it was 2007 and like how we are the
reason that other countries are invading
i know he knows that but to get hung up
on this crap man
i think and he's just doubled down and
gone crazy with him but listen listen
obviously what he said was insane
obviously the right
is not cheering for protesters being
arrested who are opposing this obviously
they're not out there supporting putin
he's trying to make it seem like because
tucker carlson says that putin does not
like western influence in ukraine here's
the perspective that it's support of
putin but then what happens is a bunch
of other american establishment left
personalities defend his incentive
for tribal reasons
because the right now mocks genter
they're going to come out back he's
right it's a fact now his psychotic
statement is now a fact among these
leftists the battle of cult worship and
ignore ignoring the fact that what
tucker carlson is saying is a mere fact
yeah tucker talking about the fact that
vladimir putin is uh hostile towards
western european influence is a fact
that's not that's not a
it's not a supporting statement of any
kind there's no emotion in that
statement that is a black and white fact
they said he echoed putin's talking
points echoed he literally told his
audience what putin said he's educating
oh yeah it's it's amazing
to echo talking points i believe putin
says
the that that
the the the ukrainian administration is
a western puppet and then tucker cross
on his show says vladimir putin views
ukraine as a western puppet
the the in 2014 you know the ousting of
yanukovych and they're like he's echoing
his talking points well how else is
supposed to tell people what's happening
in that country i feel like there's one
step further
i feel like this is a step further on
the removing the context thing like what
they did with joe rogan he said the
n-word supposedly whatever they
completely removed all contacts they
made it seems like he was insulting
someone so now what they do with tucker
say he's echoing his talking points just
by saying that this is what he said he's
reporting the news he's telling his
journalists exactly he actually is a
journalist in fact that's misleading
telling someone someone's talking point
is different than echoing though exactly
echoing would be like yeah and i think
that's really bad too exactly i'll put
it this way
the way tucker explained what was going
on he spoke factually but it was very
much
what it's
there are certain things that are
happening in ukraine that vladimir putin
has stated which are
easy facts
simply by saying here's a fact of
something that happened in ukraine
the issue is
u.s corporate press lies
they've been they lied about joe biden
they lied about joe biden as quid pro
quo and if you tell the truth on that
you're echoing putin
amazing joe biden absolutely engaged in
a legal quid program you're talking
about his barisma and vladimir putin
sees that
and he says
so
the prosecutor in the administration is
fired because putin uh because i'm sorry
because biden
uh
threatened to to take away illegally by
mind you
aid from the united states it's so
obviously an american puppet that
country oh you're you're you're you're
equing putin now that that salinity you
see how that works now now just by
observing
corruption
you are now in support technically
so the russian agendas are in support of
me because it was my i saw it coming two
years ago and i claimed it then
the silinsky stuff is not dude biden
goes in there he he basically i don't
know what you would call browbeated the
president to fire a guy that was uh
examining his a company that his son was
on the board of so the president fired
the guy
and then went by and then when that was
when biden was a vp when he left office
after trump gets in the guy comes back
he bragged about it he bragged about it
on stage yeah we've talked about this so
many times it's so important to
understand this but in a video of him
doing it
say that then you're echoing you know
russian propaganda and it's easy
i want to i want to now get into sort of
the um
what's the right word irreverence of the
psychosis here we have this story
i don't i don't know what this is sis
mocked actress oh actress is mocking
jesus proofreader
for uploading a video of herself reading
a self-penned poem saying she wishes
she'd been putin's mom
so she could have hugged him to stop him
turning into a warmonger actress anna
lynn mccord 34 posted a bizarre poem
online thursday about her desire to be
putin's mother
putin 69 ordered a full-scale invasion
of ukraine okay do they have this
let's play it because it could oh wait i
got to turn this down on don't i yeah
okay we got this is going to be you guys
ready for this one yeah
okay here we go
dear president vladimir putin
i'm so sorry that i was not your mother
that was when i paused at the first time
oh come on
stupid things not working i was like
this is cringe it's really quiet anyway
all right is it gonna work
never with the stories plight the world
unfurled before our eyes a pure demise
of nations sitting peaceful under a
night sky all right we're not going to
listen to this
the problem i have with that is it
wasn't genuine she wasn't saying it she
was just reading a pill
with like cadence to it it didn't sound
like she actually meant it
that was why i i just got to say like
that's unbearably critical oh my gosh
something is we we have a malignancy in
in in this in this country
of vapid shells of people
who do things like this
where they're like i don't know about
ukraine i don't care about russia i
heard the name putin in the news
let me make a video you know what social
media was a mistake yep there are just
some people that shouldn't be allowed to
post yep i am kidding this is a joke
they should be censored all right maybe
miners shouldn't be able to post i don't
know
she's 34 ian she should know you look at
this she's half the age you look at this
it's so absurd you don't even know what
what to start with it's
who is this
hollywood actress and what does she have
to do or what does she know about
90210 man come on don't you know and
what does this poem help i mean this is
this is typical like america like the
toxic american culture where we think
like you know if enough hearts bleed and
we you know and we shed enough tears and
hashtag hard enough like we're gonna
solve world problems like like this is
gonna come across vladimir putin's desk
and
and a tear is gonna like yeah what just
a single tear is gonna just drop from
his like stone stature and and you know
what he's gonna say
let's pull back he's gonna slam the
table and
she was right and i too wish you were my
mother
i think this this reminds me of um
there's this like kind of idea like oh
if i go back and help hitler when he was
a baby and like give him the kindness he
needed to become an artist maybe you
wouldn't become a psychoactive
psychoactive psychological dictator but
uh i think that's this idea he didn't do
drugs though yeah he was all on
amphetamines and that stopped he was
just shell shocked from world war one
destroyed mind
this girl i think is doing that with
putin she's like oh if i could have if
somehow i could have reached his inner
child that maybe he wouldn't be so vile
no i'm very cynical about this have you
guys ever heard this lady's name before
in your life no no no no ian no this
person never heard of this lady no yeah
i haven't either until today hey look
she's getting it said she was on 90210
so i guess that makes her somewhat
credible yeah i mean she's got like two
hundred thousand followers
i would imagine right the 900 reboot
yeah
i know the original i was your mother
you would have been so loved
oh man
so they're trying
this is like this is uh this is american
you know uh toxic culture trying or
hollywood culture trying to tie this to
like toxic masculinity in some way we're
a silly people dude
and again look at our priorities we're
like putin like you know if you just had
a mother it would be okay and it's like
let's not talk about like look at any of
the other he's got the factors in this
his mom's like
look at this
look at look at hold on hold on there's
a picture i say although mccord blames
the family matriarch putin's mother
maria
shalomova has been characterized by
others as a kind factory worker who
secretly baptized him
could you imagine you know if anything
what's gonna happen putin's gonna be
like what'd you say about my mom
yeah i can get i understand wanting to
emotionally connect with vladimir putin
right now and you have the technology to
do it so you may as well try but don't
read a script man there's a poem that
you wrote that you're
come on do it genuinely if you're gonna
do it otherwise you're just you're just
burning the ground you walk on
it's just there's so much insanity this
is this isn't the only insane thing
there's this this post from a lady and
she's like
the only reason that putin's allowed to
wage war is because he's white i was
just trying to find that as as we were
reading this other headline if a black
or brown man had invaded ukraine it
would have been swiftly dealt with and
it's like it would have been a loud they
said it would have it wouldn't have been
allowed
like none of this is allowed and again
that goes to the it just goes to
highlight how little these people
actually understand
the the gravity and the severity of the
situation that is unfolding right before
our eyes these people vote
that's scary it is it's it's very scary
you know and and i think it was thomas
edison that said that said the greatest
that's the you know the greatest threat
to a democracy is an uneducated public
and we are looking at
millions of them at this point yep oh
man zombie hordes
you know people who vote with their
emotions you know i'm i'm quite certain
that this woman went out and and
probably voted against trump because she
thought his tweets were mean yep that's
exactly it this that's a good point this
story of this woman saying if i was your
mother you had been so held it shows the
stupidity the ignorance
and and i would i would bet a large sum
of money she voted joe biden oh for sure
yeah i would i would
i would absolutely bet that i i cannot
imagine i mean who knows maybe she she
voted for trump i really doubt it it's
crazy you know
you see these people and they say things
like well it's a good thing trump's not
president and i'm like is it but it's
bad like the bad thing happened
like it didn't all of that all of the
things that you said were going to
happen under trump are happening right
now yep the bad things didn't happen
under trump exactly it's all happening
now
it's remarkable that they're like well
if if trump was president everything
would be a whole lot worse and it's like
but it wasn't you had him as president
the economy was great putin didn't
invade ukraine biden gets in and then he
does within a year
and you think the issue is putin would
have done it anyway
and it would have been worse with trump
all right man
some people are just lost no i don't
think you can even start to reason with
that because that's
that's that
they have they have already made up
their mind and and any anything you
throw is going to lead them back to
their original conclusion no matter what
yeah
and it's it comes from just a genuine
lack of understanding i think to the
severity of the situation and and lydia
what you were saying earlier about how
the um
the the less people understood where
ukraine was the more the more they
wanted intervention i guarantee that if
you put a globe in front of this this
young lady here that she will not be
able to find ukraine yeah at all
absolutely probably five guesses and she
probably still would not be able to get
it you could play wordle with her and
say guess the letters and she still
would be like
what's
it's like it's pronounced ukraine
i thought it was u-c-r-a-n-e
close but not quite
this is why i'm talking about just
buying all those coconuts and sitting
back and just machete
machete them open and see that straw in
there and just sit back i remember the
good old days i went to rio once
dollar it's like a buck for a coconut
yeah everywhere you sit on the beach you
walk right out of your hotel and you sit
on the beach and just get a coconut
copacabana right there have you ever
been yes oh it's amazing i went during
carnival
yes
and they got snacks and food we got
street food yeah and meat on a stick
right in the street right yep yeah it's
good living see that's what i'm thinking
about
well uh i do have a brazilian visa there
you go i'm just thinking you know as it
all comes crumbling down maybe maybe we
should spend time with our loved ones
and smile and uh it's like have you seen
the movie don't look up
at the end when they're all at the table
holding hands and it's like the world's
about to end i'm like that's kind of how
i feel right now i know i i feel very i
made a video last night that i didn't
end up uploading because it was so it
got so dark like i
i i i want to believe that
we're better than animals but we're just
animals someone so someone super chatted
she was trying to kill putin by getting
him to die laughing
could you imagine if like
this story comes out that putin had a
stroke
and then like
there's a photo of him on the ground
confirming it and on his phone is a
picture of the woman and a big smile on
his face
and then someone's like i think he
laughed himself into a stroke and died i
think this woman wore his over i think
this woman stopped world war iii
she actually did it the mad woman all it
took was one poem yeah you know i wanted
to ask you ian about attila's gym a
little bit before we go super chats you
guys down um
i don't know we haven't talked about it
really well we we we should uh i want to
briefly mention just a little bit uh
just what's going on with taiwan and
then you know maybe 30 seconds
so
we didn't we didn't talk about it all
too much but i just want to make sure we
squeeze this in a little bit
at fox news uh reports taiwan warns
chinese aircraft flying an air defense
zone day of russia ukraine invasion this
is just um
i mean this is this is just china being
like you know we're going to whip it out
we're going to flap it around because we
can the u.s is in in a rough spot you're
totally distracted it's they they do
this they do it often the pressing on
taiwan
but i think this is um man
you know in all seriousness we could
talk about this lady being crazy but
there's
there's
i'm worried about what's gonna what's
coming you know what i mean that's what
we get for invading iraq and not not
getting our government out of there man
well it goes
it goes right along with with what we
said earlier you know what do you do do
you step in
and you step into ukraine right do we
do we commit x amount of troops there
right
just just walk through it you know you
say you put 50 000 troops there okay
then then what happens when the chinese
say okay well
you know
we see you have 50 000 troops in ukraine
and
we're gonna put a hundred thousand
on taiwan if we're taking
what's america's next step in that
situation and and how
how far do our alliances and
entanglements go before we say this is
not
going to end well for anybody and we're
going to step out of this yeah the
taiwan but at the same time how do you
just let
these things happen if we if we're
taking our border protection off our own
border to go to poland china knows we
are spread too thin we've already gone
too far yeah dude and that's canada i
would read that exactly the same way if
i was in in charge of the chinese
military yeah america's in disarray
right now thank god well let's let's
let's spend a couple minutes talking
about uh attilas well think about taiwan
the last thing i'll say is in a war game
scenario what do you do with taiwan if
it's invaded do you level it to the
ground like scorched earth and like no
one can have it this is where you make
60 of the world's microchips or
processing like computer soft you can't
give that to your enemy in a war
scenario you can't so what it's like
blowing up a factory that makes the atom
bomb before they take it over you can't
let them have that factory but i've
never been in taiwan i don't know the
scope and scale of leveling the island
of the ground why would we do that
because if if you allow the chinese to
take control of the production killing
millions of people no they would do it
systematically before they left the
island they would blow up all the
infrastructure and the chinese aren't
going to let anybody off that island bro
millions of people aren't going to blow
up their own you know homeland and flee
that's a loser most people don't get
away they're getting worse you probably
don't hear a lot about and the chinese
probably know that the chinese probably
know that
if they step into taiwan it is a
lose-lose scenario for for the american
military what do we have what is it
going to take to defend taiwan it
it would take probably a full-scale war
and
that becomes a game of chicken
china says hey we're going to do it yeah
and we say no you better not no
well
we're gonna do it your border patrol
agents are over in ukraine right now
you're helpless yeah how how strong are
you
you know and if if you're somebody like
taiwan who is on an aggressive
footing and you're looking at joe biden
in the way he's handled everything so
far
i'm going to call your bluff
and and if if that's something that i i
wanted to do
i wouldn't look at the united states
right now as a credible
threat
the chinese said it straight to i think
was anthony blinken they said the us is
not coming from from a position of
strength
yeah
it's you know you know i was thinking
we're talking about this stuff like the
soviet union united states
you got these two like jocks on the
playground you know fighting each other
and there's some like fat asian kid
chubby kid in the corner who's like not
part of the the fight or anything now
everyone's older and going to high
school and they see the kid for the
first time and he's six foot tall and
super ripped and he's like get out of my
way yeah exactly and now the fight
between you know the russian kid and the
american kid is getting interesting
because the the ripped asian kid is
walking up to the russian guy like i got
your back bro
it's like oh yeah the russians guys like
i'ma pick you first and the chinese
guy's like no i'm gonna pick you first
get it they want to be the leader they
want to be the team captain somebody
mentioned that uh it's called the dragon
bear
china and russia
the dragon it's a horrifying creature
so like world war iii is what the the
silly nannies versus the dragon bears no
it would be corporations versus i don't
think none of those countries nobody
really wants to accept the corporate
drones like they don't care and i mean
literally physical drones mechanical
drones they don't have any feelings and
then the people that are locked into the
corporate media they don't care because
their their emotions are drained
well we saw uh i don't know if you guys
saw the the cnn clip where they're um
yes
which one
so there's literal bombings it's kiev
it's oh that's right the air right side
i mean if if there's not if there's not
more of a encounter dude can we play if
you've ever seen the movie idiocracy
yeah i mean that is like you're like wow
we are we are live in part two right
they are posted they're putting apple
b's five or five you know uh happy hour
deals it's the most right over top of
literal bombing footage this is great
and in the worst way this is not great
there it is you guys
ready wait wait i'm gonna start it over
this is from here we go here we go 19
seconds long
[Music]
brought to you by
[Music]
i gotta admit though the air raid sirens
lead up
and then and then when i heard it i was
like i'm watching these air raid sirens
and i'm like this is the end
but a cold beer on a friday night sounds
pretty good yeah
and most americans probably had that
similar experience to that terrifyingly
it's like war brought to you by
applebee's war till friday then i get to
have my beer and my chicken wings like
dude why would this you know someone
pressed the button yeah like so when we
do live stream there's a button on
youtube where i can turn an ad on we
never do it but you can click it and
then you know a certain amount of people
who are watching see an ad it's
pointless to do
someone at cnn it was like now
it's my last day yeah here i go no
there's this network anyway they were
like this kind of this kind of jams yeah
right let's get it i love this stuff
yeah drop the beans
they're like because because they have
like a i think they have like a they
have a switcher so they're the someone
heard the air raid sirens and then was
like they're like waiting for them
they got turn tables switches
yeah bring it up
and then you have that like that dude
doing the weird butt shuffle it's like
in reverse is the weirdest thing and
it's still showing the the the air raids
like it's background
wow that is that is american idiocy yup
it is it's i mean that's i remember
watching that movie
10
15
years ago
and laughing at it because like that's
so absurd and it's like wow well that's
you know the only thing they need like
next is a commercial about like you know
electrolytes i actually actually i like
applebee's
they got good they got like they got
they got good wings i don't know how
they what they fry stuff in that's my
only i don't know i'll tell you this i
never i didn't like applebee's i wasn't
sure it's probably not good whatever it
is i went to an applebee's i got sick
and the food was awful i was like i'm
never coming here again bees
but we were ordering and they have this
trick where you go on grubhub oh yeah
and it was called something like it was
like libby's barbecue or something i
can't remember
and then i was like i'm gonna oh no it
was like kitchen wings and then i was
like we're gonna order wings and sauce
and so i ordered a bunch of wings and
when it came it came in applebee's bags
and i was like they tricked me
they create fake restaurants that serve
only a certain thing
so that people who are like i don't want
applebee's i want wings
will still buy from applebee's and then
i was like it's actually pretty good and
so now we just straight order from
applebee's sometimes that's actually the
old baby switch
they got applebee's cheese sticks before
i got into like health consciousness
that was i love the apples are they the
ones who have the coconut shrimp because
that's really good too so with like that
like sriracha i worked there like years
and years and years ago as like a
teenager i'm sure it's probably still on
the menu what was your position server
oh nice
before you were 18. yeah like oh cool we
also order from ruby tuesdays we we we
live kind of in the middle of nowhere so
we have like we have few options yeah a
few choices you know it's like either
pick up from a local pizzeria or
something or you can order from like
these medium-sized chains can you give
us a brief update on um attila's because
we're about to go to super chat about a
minute yeah absolutely status we are
still open we just actually passed 365
000 registered visits to the facility we
still have a voluntary contact tracing
system in in place
we put that in place originally just so
that nobody could say hey you're
spreading coronavirus and to date we've
had no outbreaks linked to the facility
we have a storage unit full of 365 000
slips of paper
just to prove a point
but we're open every day we have no less
than 500 healthy happy people coming
through we're still in the court system
we have an appeals process going
on um
with all of the fines and the hundreds
of thousands of dollars that they find
us we have an appeal process going on to
sue the township so that we can get our
business license back because we shut
down our billing in march of 2020 and
have not resumed it since and uh and
we're finally getting to municipal court
that was kicked down the road
for two years because of covid and
that's where we can actually bring forth
like legitimate arguments about
constitutional violations and things of
the sort we've been narrowed to very um
very narrow scopes of argument um being
caught with court orders and stuff like
that and we also just pled guilty to
criminal contempt of court for the
heinous crime of taking our doors off of
the hinges
and we got one year of probation for
that wow what do you mean by we like
your store or you uh me and my business
partner wow yeah the company got charged
or you guys get it no individually we
got charged they they pierced through
the llc for all of this so so we're all
we're personally liable for the hundreds
of thousands if not millions of dollars
of fines
um and they they brought criminal
criminal
citations against both frank and i to
give context attila's you guys basically
right when kova came out and they
started putting lockdowns and shutdowns
you guys just basically said no we're
staying two months in we reopened um day
three or four is when we decided that we
were going to reopen but we took our
time over the next like six weeks
to develop a very comprehensive safety
protocol program because we knew
that we were going to get pushback and
we didn't want to just open just to you
know just to
to open recklessly you know we wanted to
open because at the time we truly
believe that covet was a credible threat
but that there could be some sort of
happy medium between shutting the world
down
and
and and mitigating you know the spread
of covet um so we opened two months
after in may of 2020 and we've been open
ever since no matter what they did
all right let's go to super chats though
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only segment coming up for you around 11
or so p.m we're gonna be talking about
conspiracy theories about why vladimir
putin really attacked it'll be
interesting it has something to do with
bio labs you'll not want you'll want to
check this one out yeah well let's get
into the super chats for now get your
super chats in now and we will we'll try
and read as many as we can
all right
laparti says
i don't know how alex jones does it but
he called it again check out the video
from memology 101. he was right again
all right i love looking at it this
might be a video i think i saw from last
october where alex was like uh
apparently my sources are telling me
there's going to be some sort of
military war conflict in february
it's really from my sources
proven right by time yeah this is
awesome he's got a pretty good track
record over time of of being right ahead
of the curve i think he knows a little
bit
there's a lot of noise in there yeah a
lot of stuff he says is noise well when
you throw a lot of you know crap at the
wall you know some of it will stick but
i think i think he's been right on some
pretty
pretty important things
yeah along the way
ryan johnson says uh johnston sorry as
much as i despise the administration i
will go back into the usmc if we have
world war iii because it is the best
hope for the survival of the
constitution my life is swore uh the
constitution to the constitution
right on i respect that tremendously
that's
that's a scary thing to sign up for yeah
willingly
omg puppy says america did fan the
flames they led ukraine in the path to
destruction with the kuritan 2014 and
encouraging them to antagonize russia
and become a nuclear nato member russia
could not permit that there wasn't there
was a uh you call it a coup but the
president was removed this is when he
got put into office is that i don't know
if i don't know if it was a lenski was
it was it zenski or was it check that
out was it who was remembered it might
have been
yeah take a look at who was was
was it porshenko or was he i'm not sure
i don't know
but uh yanukovych was ousted and he was
the he was the the president of the
country
uh kt skye says you are always wrong ian
is always right oh well there you go
only a sith deals in absolutes
[Laughter]
okay let's grab some more super chits
here
grand cay says didn't biden give a list
to putin of infrastructure not to attack
after one meeting could this whole thing
be planned with china and russia given
all the connection between them and the
elites no i don't know that sounds
ridiculous because you know putin's
he's he's two headstrong he's too into
himself i really doubt it but um
biden giving a list of things not to
attack was like just pathetic diplomacy
where he was like all right if you do
attack us just don't do these and
everyone's like did you just give them a
list of critical infrastructure to
attack yep that's kind of what that is
again that's going back to that idea
that we shouldn't really be talking open
strategy uh or weaknesses yeah you know
in our mainstream media we should kind
of keep that stuff under wraps
are seni
yat senyuk was the uh interim governor
governor for ukraine after the
revolution government petro poroshenko
yeah he was governing until poroshenko
became president all right mr slendy
says these aren't goat farmer militias
in the desert anyone who has has been
spoiled by the proxy wars on the other
side of the world wake up these are
enemies who can reach out and touch us
with fire and death
yikes man that's true it's very true
man
alex law says all russia has to do is
turn off the gas supply to europe if
anyone including the u.s retaliates in
any way that's right yep that is true
and correct and scary
wow man
it's not like we're gonna uh come in and
and subsidize that anyway yeah
bobcat says tim room 34 is real but that
substation can only run the subways on
the island not the whole system like the
legend says interesting that's a secret
room what they call it room 34 room 34
no i don't think that's true is that is
that what it's called that's cool though
that's uh is that what it's called he
seems like that's what you're talking
about is that really
[Music]
oh inside the secret life of new york's
grand central there you go is that what
it is maybe yeah
architecturaldigest.com
huh i think i read in the new york times
oh grand central is amazing and we were
talking about um having privatizing the
train tracks or like having not
privatized giving naming rights to the
infrastructure and having like uh um
amazon and fedex
bring
create like hubs in the city and then
overhaul and maintain all the tracks be
cool to have a big
grand central like shopping mall i think
at grand central that'd be really cool
all right alex hilbert says hey tim i'm
a paratrooper in the 82nd that works in
an s2 shop intelligence i appreciate
your attention to detail and i have to
say keep up the good work ian keep
rolling 20s hey thanks man i really
appreciate it thank you man i mean look
i i read a lot of different news sources
and i try and you know when claims are
made i try and find alternate sources
and i try to find root sources to make
sure that i'm getting the real legit
information
and when a lot of the information is
based off of
videos on twitter it's like how do you
really confirm it like when someone
posts a video of a tank rolling and i'm
like how do i know that's russia yeah
yeah because i don't know where that is
just because it says that luke tweeted
out like airplanes flying overhead and
it was like the russian invasion has
commenced and people in the comments
were like this is from a year ago this
is like a flying exercise
you know this morning when i woke up i
heard quite a bit of air traffic
we're really we're really close to dc
out here interesting and so there were
some helicopters and some other you know
flights sometimes we see ospreys it's
cool you ever see those we're like they
have the props that can turn up and go
forward yeah those are cool
yeah i wonder where they're going but um
you know dc's nearby plus we got mount
weather right over here i told luke that
he needs to get out of florida i was
like you don't want to be in florida
right now because it's a peninsula and
you know i don't know what's going to
happen but if you're concerned about
this escalating florida's not a good
place to be and he's like you're right
next to mount weather she's like the
emergency bunker and i'm like i didn't
say we were in a good spot i'm just we
just have better ways to exit yeah right
well no but i'm not even i'm just saying
like florida's not a good place to be if
you think war's coming
all right james rogers says tim i really
wish you'd stop pushing this narrative
that we're all going to war all we will
do is push sanctions and give aid russia
is manufacturing a false narrative and
your hatred of biden is making you fall
for it stop i actually gave credit to
biden i think
i think james you might
might be uh have an optimism bias or a
normalcy bias i actually said i don't
blame biden for everything that's going
on i don't i think vladimir putin's
exploiting a situation he's long wanted
to pursue i think a lot of the problems
we've been facing with the inflation is
easily attributable to kovid but i think
joe biden did a bad job as well yeah and
when it comes to the situation in
ukraine uh biden isn't entirely at fault
he's mishandling the situation but a lot
of a lot of the
restrictions and and and the things you
have to take into into account are from
years and years of foreign policy
you know so he's even if he's making the
wrong choices he's operating
on a playing field that he didn't
necessarily lay out in front of him so
is it his fault entirely no
but he's the one steering the ship so i
think that we should be looking towards
him to make the best decisions that he
can
given the set of circumstances in front
of him and on top of that i just want to
point out i mean when have we talked
about stripping out a nuclear power from
the swift payment system
or the u.s directly attacking russia
this is not we're we're not talking
about afghanistan or iraq we it's not
proxy wars it's not syria this is the
u.s being like two superpowers
is russia superpower i guess they are
they still are they got nukes their
their their gdp is nowhere near you know
the u.s in china but yeah the size of
florida
yeah uh see that's why putin's mad
because he used to be a bully on the
playground
he keeps rolling through eastern europe
you know he's going to have a little bit
more in that that's right and then
armory and and
when you have china who has clearly
backed him already
i mean
that doesn't matter so much that he's
got a small smaller gdp also if you're
calculating gdp if they've got a
trillion gdp and fiat you've got a
trillion gdp in bitcoin your bitcoin
trillion is worth a lot more than that
trillion fiat if you measure to
calculate the way the fiat is headed
inflation-wise so gdp may look small on
paper but it might be better currency
all right keegan mooney says fourth
attempt this week
in the immortal words of dr jordan v
peterson watch attack on titan real
quote real life parallels are only
getting realer really i've only seen a
little bit of a tech on insight and i
should check it out so they fight the
giants yeah the titans shows wild
and they've got these weird things on
their hips that have like that fire
cable so they can launch themselves in
the air really disturbing art worth
seeing just put your eyes on it to see
the art it's really weird really crazy
hank mccormick's has a hundred suitcase
size nukes missing from the russian
stockpile since the 90s how many russian
sleeper cells are out there
i don't know man but maybe there's tom
cruise with a crack team of special
agents keeping us safe no doubt what if
what if tom cruise actually was the
secret agent for mission impossible and
the movies are to cover up the
explosions they say they're just doing
stunts
fighter pilot and top that's right right
that proves it yep
yeah
he does he does a lot of his own stunts
out here though he broke his foot that
one time filming mission impossible he
jumped between two roofs and then like
roof two that rooftop stunt man
yep
all right
let's see we got here
christopher massey says as an afghan vet
i feel qualified to say not only did the
idiots in the swamp lose a winnable war
but it took 11 years to kill a guy that
was living in caves but they're going to
outsmart putin
man that's why i'm saying i'm like no
it's
and these are the people that that we
should be listening to not uh not the
girl reading the poem you know on the
internet these are people who have
experienced conflict and who understand
that there's really no winners in this
situation and that we we should
be
trying to resolve this as diplomatically
as possible and with with as few
casualties as possible because
any american conflict in the past 20 30
years has not brought this country
any any form of good it's only it's only
hurt people like this these veterans and
and
we know a lot of these guys because
these are these are the guys that come
to our gym
you know and these are the guys that
have seen it and and seen that
these are not these are not wars that we
want to get involved in we want to
prevent these wars if anything
yeah all right we got uh amy beth quinn
says tim can you give a big shout out to
wes a fan of yours who is currently
hauling my family's stuff in a semi from
washington to tennessee as we move from
tyranny to more freedom and lydia i have
a super guest recommendation for you
check out jim stroud on rumble and
anchor dot fm i will do that shout out
wes very cool nice job wes
vicidia says you really need to get
scott horton of antiwar.com on he broke
down the politics and history of the
ukraine russia conflict expertly on dave
smith's podcast we fit scott right we
have yeah we skated with him yeah he
came on the show and then afterwards
it's like midnight he's like escaped the
mini ramp and i was like bro it's a
minute i got to wake up but i did a
kickflip pivot
so bonus that's that's sick trick and i
was very stoked oh wow
um it would be cool to have dave smith
and scott on yeah that's a good idea if
if they're available yeah it'd be great
to have some anti-war personalities
talking about what's going on
let's see we got here in these super
chats
richard bloom says when has any
communist or fascist or bully ever had
enough study economics growth through
expansion is the only way they succeed
chris williams says why do you think
russia wants chernobyl so badly
i
i think they want to secure the country
symbolism no i don't think they want the
channel so badly i think they moved into
the north chernobyl is very close to
kiev and they're taking strategic points
they they can use it to their advantage
and they're going to move into uh tkv
there you go man
alan rogers says so much for 69th
generational propaganda site digital
warfare hey tim looks like guns tanks
and planes are here to stay oh i never
said they were we're gonna be gone i was
saying that a key portion of the war is
gonna like like war will be fought
through propaganda but what you gotta
understand about hot war with planes
tanks guns and all the stuff is when
the propaganda stops working then you
escalate your tensions you know are we
gonna see uh nukes launched we've seen
gravity bombs dropped in world war ii
and that was it we gonna see icbms be
actually used for the first time i
certainly hope not but they could be
could be man
seth says was delighted to tune in
tonight to see you were able to get
nordic kratos on oh yeah did people call
you that or something
i love it no but i'm guessing he was
talking about me yeah yeah i got a
feeling
oh yeah it's kratos the guy from god of
war yeah oh yeah yeah you do look like
him he's a beast
how fitting for tonight's show yeah yes
let's i've been talking about
de-escalation of conflict the entire
night i'm not doing my job no
livin says do you think this will result
in biden having to re-establish our
energy independence rolling back
restrictions on fracking and restoring
keystone now i i did want to read this
even though we did address it because i
just want to uh reiterate
biden recently in the past few days
suspended leases on oil and gas yes 20
seconds that would be that would be a
fantastic step in the right direction
from joe biden would you know i would i
would take him a lot more seriously as
somebody who is protecting the interests
of this country
if i saw a move like that you know we
were saying the other day is could could
you imagine if on on this for the state
of the union he comes out and he's like
my fellow americans
i've done a bad job inflation's through
the roof our policies haven't worked war
has erupted in eastern europe and we're
not trying to handle it afghanistan was
an absolute disaster was on my watch and
my fault and i'm sorry
could you imagine jesus i'd respect him
if he did that i would too i would be
like wow i feel like all right man
i after after coming clean and saying
all that and just owning up to it i'd be
like
let me know what you need i'll help you
fix it you got it you come out here
honestly that would be a powerful
statement from from any world leader
right but
good luck getting that could you i i'm
sorry like someone super chats the other
day they were like they're like god
bless his speech writers for the state
of the union what are they going to
write
this has been a terrible past year they
put up offense already i don't know what
you're going to write about it was worse
than it was under trump there were more
deaths inflation is through the roof gas
prices have doubled there's a there's
afghanistan was bungled there's a war
breaking out in europe
we could have seen it all coming what if
he quits what if he's like i'm out and
he drops the mic i'm going to get some
ice cream and then i was like is this
thing on
what would actually be way better if he
comes out with his aviator sunglasses
and he's got the ice cream cone and he's
like
and then instead of speaking he just
goes like
you're screwed bucko he walks out i
don't know jack look fat yeah
look fat i love it he should just come
out with one of those stories where he
starts just talking about like kids
touching his legs
he should just just come out right from
the rip with something that has nothing
to do with the state of the union and
then just do one of those like shuffles
where he walks away real quick as
everybody's just bewildered trying to
ask questions yes
yeah i mean now's the time yeah dramatic
exit he's got an audience
rm says you are missing the point the
u.s enticed ukraine to give up their
nuclear arsenal and agreed to back
ukraine and russia if russia came
knocking does anyone think russia would
invade if ukraine had nukes that's right
yes some people were mentioning there
was a deal the usa with ukraine that we
would back them up
i don't know about it i don't know
but there we go man i'd like to know
more about that if you guys have any
info
odd stance says i hope people can now
realize there are no right sides when it
comes to war the victor writes the
history books hopefully people will now
realize that fact when you're getting to
a pissing contest you don't win you just
get covered in piss yep yep
wrestling with a pig john l says russia
won't buy bitcoin putin will buy all fjb
coin
wouldn't that be really funny
that would be an interesting turn of
events awesome the new standard
[Laughter]
just by fjb
you're gonna see a spike in that today
the russia going to crypto is kind of
like a hope i don't know if it's likely
but that's like a hope of mine likely
what would happen if they got cut off
from swift
they'd have to create their own currency
whether it be a central bank coin or a
piece of crypto that went on a
blockchain i don't know
yeah i mean either way they're they're
obviously going to come up with some
sort of solution trackable
even if it's a i mean even if they don't
go to crypto they're going to go to some
sort of other payment system and you
don't think that that china would hop on
board with that very quickly
china can exist in both so so why
wouldn't all these
why wouldn't all these these big you
know uh economic countries in that part
of the world say yeah well we'll use
that one too you'd see american
corporations spinning up russian
currency if they did that and being like
i'm playing both sides just like henry
ford did in world war ii yeah i mean so
whether or not it goes crypto or it
stays on fiat i mean that's a bad idea
regardless i think that that's something
that needs to just get pulled off the
table immediately
hunter killer says a nuclear winter will
cancel out global warming yeah there you
go that's the plan greta will be happy
yeah i i don't know if that's true but
yeah it may not work exactly
[Laughter]
what does snope say about that yeah
right
yeah
andrew alvarez says i'm running for u.s
house in texas trying to primary an
incumbent texas primary elections are
march first wish me luck keep america
working and our families safe everybody
please right now look up when your local
primaries are and get rid of these
incumbents yes i don't care if they're
democrats or republicans tell them to go
away
it's happened before i think it was like
in the 50s like all the incumbents got
voted out and then just
all new uh people on both sides was it
good did it turn out pretty good i don't
know i think that's something that
should happen regularly you know and
part part of the problem
i think that we we have in in our
political culture is that people don't
pay attention until it's time to go to
the ballot box so they haven't really
they haven't in essence they haven't
really selected their candidate
you know such a small portion of people
take part in the primaries of their
parties that whoever's on the ballot
they just vote for but they don't really
know much about them you know there's so
many better options
that are
not making it through that initial cut
because
merely just because people aren't paying
attention to it
you know i i don't know what the
percentage is but it's a dim percentage
uh the amount of people who who pay
attention in the primary
um compared to those who show up in the
general election and that's i mean you
want to start seeing change you know
that that's a good place to start as an
individual
tiberius says the real tragedy is that
hunter biden lost his job f
oh
damn
tina collette says on climate change
climate cost et cetera just remember one
good volcanic eruption and the world
temperature dropped several degrees
immediately for years oh that's what we
need there you go yeah and if you get uh
uh you know a yellowstone eruption yeah
then you get uh the sun blocked out and
break out those coconuts that's right
sit back and put your feet him and say
all right man
kevin clark says metal gear is great i
love the boss the end everyone you kill
comes back to haunt you during it it
really makes you think about your
actions and their impact oh that's
awesome love tim caskey but the great
work appreciate it man i like played the
first metal gear you said you played i
played a couple of them as a sniper no i
would just run through it just kill
people yeah i like tried to like hide in
the box but like the guard were always
trying to just pop out and kill them
games kelsey likur says live in carroll
county maryland this morning we saw two
batches of eight to ten military
helicopters flying in formation heading
northwest from dc yup
yeah i was when i was getting ready says
like 7 30 80 a.m i could hear
helicopters
we see them every so often sometimes the
chinooks come over and stuff like that
there's a lot yeah
yep
so so you know in talking about
potential for war and everything when i
was saying i talked to luke i'm like
floor's not a good place to be and he's
like well you're by mount weather and i
thought about it and i was like no for
sure it's a hike it's a this area this
dc area is a target
probably the safest area though
you know well maybe not the safest you
know uh the bunkers of the of mountains
in colorado are probably the safest they
have like uh they i think they moved to
norad but they've got mountainous
underground bunkers you probably don't
even know about you got mount weather
but we do have uh
sam sites
throughout the dc area
so you know if if anything started
happening you got surface there missiles
i don't know if they have any way of
stopping icbms i'd imagine we've
we've had to have deployed um high power
lasers already right
that can just track and target like iron
dome if israel's got iron dome we have
i'm fairly certain that if we wanted to
stop something coming over the ocean at
us that we yeah i don't think it's not
the ice it's orbital strikes that are
yeah the next big thing they just come
from above you don't see them coming
really rob's from god or missiles from
orbit that are straight down yeah coming
straight down at you too high velocity
to even detect coming in
i think that we may want to get involved
with the military in the u.s actually
tim it's so weird to think this but like
we might be do a great service to our
species if we like go to norad and help
them or like go
we'd have to be invited but
i think that we can because you have a
voice that people listen to which we
need right now and i have at least
saying i should go to norad and like
broadcast
yeah that's the kind of thing you need
people like me and you or at least like
you like
thinkers that are
outside of this world crowd to save the
lives of
the u.s administration would be like
thanks so much for your input ian i just
read this script and it would be like
war is good vladimir putin is evil and
our war is justified
unless today if you're 18 to 26
take up arms it's an
i'm not i'm not saying all to their
i'm
adventure
death but i will do my best to protect
people that's for sure i'm not reading
the script either there there's no
circumstance where they're going to be
like thank you now please broadcast this
anti-war map i'll read the script if i
agree with the script but that's about
that or just do say your script here and
just say whatever you want to say yeah
yeah we don't need to be there to help
but in the case of bombs dropping it
dude nice to be in a box you just want
to be joe biden
joe biden is a crooked crony capitalist
criminal
all of those c's lots of c's i don't
trust a word out of that guy's mouth i
know it sucks to think that my own
government is the enemy
i don't like living like this i don't
trust the word out of putin's mouth yeah
i mean either yeah it's nuts but i think
there's one thing i can count on joe
biden's self-interest and his
self-interest requires an american an
america to exist in some form clearly
the southern border is proof he doesn't
care all that much about it
but at least he wants delaware to be
around because he's got a house there
so that's the one thing i can say putin
doesn't care about the the joe biden's
house so long as joe biden cares about
joe biden's house the peripheral areas
will probably be a bit safer than you
know so i i can trust self-interest yeah
all right chris paveto says ian rolling
low bro the navy does not emit the most
co2 a lot yes the most please check the
numbers oh we have the safest global
nuke power with carriers and subs i
trust our nukes people to operate our
plants go navy i think i said the
american military is the largest
polluter the army and the navy combined
you know definitely don't don't take my
word at face value but that's a
analytics i've seen in the past
word
trash panda says we are divided at a
time where division is dangerous and i
can't see how we get reunited seeing how
insane leftists are dark times are ahead
of us we don't
we don't maybe this is it we're nearing
250 years right yep there you go 250
years why don't you guys why don't you
do this
order yourself some papa john's
you know cheese stuffed crust
get uh get extra cheese extra sauce some
pepperoni order some wings
sit back with your friends and your
loved ones buy a machete and some
coconuts and crack them up
just sit back and drink that coconut
water get some rum it's good for you fix
your gut biome that's no joke because
that'll get your head in the game
that'll help you get your head in the
game just uh just just enjoy it because
uh
man it looks like there's gonna come a
time where you're not gonna be able to
have that pizza correct our our our papa
john's already has no no employees
there's like one guy who works there so
there's no deliveries anymore it's one
of the craziest things that i've been
seeing recently is
you know i i traveled uh recently out to
arizona for a speaking engagement you
know and i used to live in arizona
and um
wanted to go to this old restaurant that
i loved just this mongolian grill just
you know real basic
we pulled it up and it said temporarily
closed due to employee shortages yep
yeah that's that was that was the first
time and it's i mean it's not like it's
a bad restaurant it's it's good food
it's they didn't have enough people to
operate the restaurant so they
temporarily closed it high unemployment
and high
lack of employment at the same time it's
so weird it's high um it's high
unemployment but low
um
what i don't even know what the term is
seeking work
that's yeah
yeah if you stop seeking work you're not
even calculated as being no and that's
the problem is you have a tremendous
amount of people who are just not
seeking work at the time or not seeking
work on the books
because of
again because they get unemployment and
they don't want to lose it
all right yep
all right everybody
we're going to talk about this these bio
labs in ukraine this is really
interesting stuff may all just be a
conspiracy theory crossbones says
twitter banned a user who matched up the
bombing locations and u.s bioweapons
labs in ukraine putin is hitting the
deep state when he makes these attacks i
don't know if that's true
snopes says false oh okay okay and that
means it must be true
right right right well we don't know but
we're going to we're going to take a
look we're going to talk about it i
don't know if it's true it's just some
post on twitter so if you want to check
out this segment go to timcast.com and
sign up to help support our work and
that segment should be up around 11 or
so p.m you'll want to you'll want to
check this one out it's going to be a
lot of fun the reason we're doing this
one for the member segments because i
don't i think it's just a conspiracy
theory and it'll be interesting to see
but uh we could use your support keep
our journalists employed to keep this
show operating so don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show however you can
you can follow the show at tim cast irl
we're on instagram with clips you can
follow me at timcast basically
everywhere um ian smith would you like
to shout anything out sure um you can
follow me on all of my social media at
ian smith fitness that's instagram
twitter uh facebook truth social you
name it all the same tag um and if
you're interested in supporting our
campaign if you want to sign up as a
volunteer and you're in new jersey uh if
you want to help donate or you want to
learn more about the platform and policy
that we're running on uh just go to
iansmithforcongress.com i would imagine
if people believe in what you were doing
staying open that they might want to
help with legal fees somehow is that
something you're even interested in
people have been tremendously supportive
to us all the way through is there a way
easy way for people to donate yep that's
at the attilisgym.com and attila says
a-t-i-l-i-s that's got all of our
merchandise we we like more so to uh
sell merchandise that way it's not a
donation and we're actually working for
our money and that was that was kind of
the point all together is that we wanted
to work
um so people usually contribute by uh by
buying our t-shirts and stuff like that
and you know we've been extremely
blessed uh all the way through these
past two years is that we've been able
to operate selling t-shirts and and on
donations it's really really awesome
thanks for coming man uh ian crossland
check me out ian crossland.net i'll see
you guys later thank you guys for tuning
in to the irl show at the end of the
world hopefully this is not our last
show i'm sure it'll be fine we'll figure
this all out over the course of the next
few weeks hopefully um you guys may
follow me on twitter and mines.com at
sarahpatchlets we will see all of you
every single one of you become members
of timcast.com and uh check out the show
11 pm we'll see you there thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you